first semester come in here we're  supposed to be pushing them as far as we  can  a lot actually make weapons but they're  not users they just make it you're gonna  make knives use it test it beat it to  death  these strength test things I mean I've  been doing this to my own stuff for  years and that's how you improve  yes we have blades that break  but we do some crazy tests and the  blades perform great  people watch that and go holy cow a  knife can actually do that and there's  makers out there that watch that and  Elevate their idea of what their blades  can do and perform to  you never come in here going home to  break that blade back the goal is to  test that blade hopefully break the  target  [Music]  if you don't test your stuff and you use  it you shouldn't be making it